[MUSIC PLAYING]
PETE LEPAGE: Hey, everybody, and
welcome to another great
Behind the Divs.
Today, we're going to be talking
with the team behind
the new Chrome experiment,
Roll It.
So with that, I want to
introduce you guys to two of
the engineers.
Sean, why don't you go ahead
and introduce yourself?
SEAN KLASSEN: Hey, everybody.
My name is Sean Klassen.
I am one of the founders of a
company called Legwork, and
we're based out of
Denver, Colorado.
And the Google Creative Lab
came to us to help them
realize this new experiment.
They wanted to show off some
technology with WebSockets and
syncing your mobile device
with your computer.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
And Justin, do you want
to introduce yourself?
JUSTIN GITLIN: Absolutely.
I'm Justin Gitlin, also
in Denver, Colorado.
I'm one of the co-founders and
partners in a development shop
called Mode Set.
And we've worked with Sean at
Legwork before, and we all
used to work at a company
together back in the day.
So I've got a great relationship
with them, and,
yeah, so we did most of the
front end development.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
So actually, that's a good
question to start off with.
You guys are sort of two
different agencies.
How did you split the work
between the two of you guys?
SEAN KLASSEN: Yeah, I guess
originally, the Creative Lab
came to us, and they were
like, hey, we have been
prototyping with this
new technology.
We want to make a
game with it.
What do you guys
have for ideas?
And we came up with a bunch
of different things.
I remember at one time, we
were talking about making
almost like a "Guitar Hero"
type of thing, where you'd
rock out against someone and
eventually settled on where we
did with this game.
And we brought in Justin--
like he was saying, we've worked
together on a bunch of
projects, and he's awesome at
mobile development and just a
great developer in general.
And he helped us make this
thing a reality.
It is really a pretty agile
environment We had some
initial features and user
stories set up and then just
kind of kept iterating on the
design and the dev really all
the way 'til the end
and the launch, and
we run out of time.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, that's
often how it works.
It's sort of like really crazy
right up until the end, and
then once you hit the end,
you're like, this is actually
really good.
We're really impressed
with this.
So--
SEAN KLASSEN: Yeah, and it's
always nerve-racking, too,
because you've been so buried in
it, you don't know how it's
going to be received.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, absolutely.
And I want to mention to the
folks who are watching live
right now that if you have
questions that you want to ask
of either Justin or
Sean, you can post
those to Google Moderator.
The link is there on screen
somewhere that way I think.
But you can post those there.
We'll be taking those as we go
throughout our Hangout today.
But I want to ask you a little
bit about the workflow because
working between two agencies and
the Google Creative Labs
team must've been kind
of interesting.
And I know that at Google I/O
this year, one of the most
popular sessions from the Chrome
side was about the
modern mobile workflow.
What did your mobile
workflow look like?
JUSTIN GITLIN: So the workflow
from my end, from the
development side on the front
end, was writing all of the
code in a Ruby on Rails
environment.
And with that, you get all the
benefits of the Rails asset
pipeline, which concatenates
all your files, compresses
them, transcompiles any
CoffeeScript or Sass, Haml,
using Sprockets and whatever
other machineries in the asset
pipeline to make that really
seamless process.
So I've mentioned that almost
all of the custom code for
this game was written
in CoffeeScript.
And we found that to be--
we ended up with less code,
cleaner code than writing pure
JavaScript.
So that's something that we at
Mode Set generally will write
99% of the time.
It depends.
If we're writing something under
500 lines of code, and
that's the entire project,
or a quick prototype or
something, we might just write
some raw JavaScript.
But we've really come to love
the things that you gain out
of CoffeeScript.
Especially for this project,
which was quite a bit of code,
many thousands of lines of
custom code on top the
third-party product libraries
that we used and built in a
really object-oriented way.
We found that it really helps
you organize and end up with
much cleaner and less code at
the end of the project.
PETE LEPAGE: Huh.
That's interesting.
One of the questions actually
on our Moderator queue is
about why you chose
CoffeeScript, which you kind
of addressed.
But is it something you'd
recommend other folks use?
JUSTIN GITLIN: Definitely.
So obviously, you have to--
they call it transcompiling
CoffeeScript to JavaScript.
So there is one step before your
CoffeeScript is ready to
be interpreted by the browser.
And in our environment, the
Ruby on Rails environment,
it's really easy to set that
up and make it completely
transparent.
If you don't have a Ruby on
Rails environment or something
like that that's going to do
it automatically for you as
you're writing and refreshing
the page and hitting your
server, I've found that a lot
of people are using a
front-end compilation
tool called Grunt.
That seems to be a really
popular one, and I've started
playing with that.
And it's really nice.
So I'd say if you're not using
any sort of server, backing up
your code, Grunt's a great way
to go to compile and do all of
the same things pretty
seamlessly as well.
SEAN KLASSEN: We've used that
on some other projects here
ourselves when we don't want to
build any kind of back-end
system or don't have access to
do that for whatever reason.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
JUSTIN GITLIN: Because not every
project is going to have
a back end.
We've had projects where we just
upload a bunch of files
to an Apache server,
and that's it.
So I think in that case,
something like
Grunt's a great option.
In our case, we did end up
compiling the entire site down
to static files, and we used the
Ruby on Rails helpers to
do that for us.
So we just wrote a little bit
of Ruby to take our dynamic
assets and translate those into
a static file system.
PETE LEPAGE: OK.
So what other tools were you
using for your build process?
SEAN KLASSEN: Like on a higher
level, because Google Creative
Labs is in New York, we're
both in Denver.
So we needed just some
communication tools that were
pretty important.
We used Google Hangouts
almost every day.
And then we used Pivotal Tracker
to track all the
features that we were working
on and prioritize them.
And that was probably one of
the biggest, most important
tools for us.
PETE LEPAGE: Yep.
And were you using that for bug
tracking, or what were you
using that for?
SEAN KLASSEN: We used it for bug
tracking, and then we also
used it just to know what was
next in our to-do list, if
there's revisions, or how
difficult things we were going
to be, like if we were going
to hit our milestones.
And we put design items right
along with [INAUDIBLE]
development items.
PETE LEPAGE: OK.
All the design tasks were
in there as well.
Cool.
JUSTIN GITLIN: It's a good
way to sort of have some
conversation going back and
forth about bugs or features,
creating new user stories if
somebody has a brand new
feature they want to
add into the app.
It's something that we'd track
all that right there and
prioritize by sort of
ordering the list
of stories in Tracker.
So it's just a nice project
management tool.
PETE LEPAGE: And that's Pivotal
Tracker, you said?
JUSTIN GITLIN: Yep.
PETE LEPAGE: All right, cool.
So let's take one of the
questions from the folks who
are watching live.
And Manuel wants to know, how
is it possible to send the
data from the gyroscope so
fast through the web,
including all the coding and
encoding that makes such a
game possible?
JUSTIN GITLIN: So the key
technology there is
WebSockets.
So if you're not familiar with
WebSockets, it's a lower
level, faster protocol.
Rather than using HTTP requests,
it creates more of a
direct connection between your
machine, a server, and then
another machine--
or any number of machines.
But in our case, for Roll It, it
was your mobile device and
your laptop.
And all those messages are
going through a server
somewhere else, which I think a
lot of people are surprised
at how quickly you can get those
messages transmitting.
We were sending about 15 to 20
messages a second during
certain parts of the game,
specifically during gameplay
for some of the ambient elements
to have a little tilt
based on the accelerometer data
coming in, as well as on
the menu screens, the entire
menu sort of tilts back and
forth, and you get a little ball
rolling across the screen
to show what your menu
selection is.
And in our case, we're only
sending a really small amount
of data for that, pretty much
just the tilt angle.
PETE LEPAGE: Right.
So that effectively, in the
document, or in the case study
that you guys wrote, it looks
like that's only maybe 50
bytes or so to send the tilt.
Is that right?
JUSTIN GITLIN: Yeah, Something
really tiny like that.
It's a really small JSON object
that gets transmitted
over WebSockets and picked
up on the other device.
So yeah.
I mean, obviously, the smaller
you can keep that data
transmitting, the quicker
it's going to go.
And the chance of losing
messages along the way due to
latency would be decreased.
So obviously, in our case,
you want to make that as
small as you can.
SEAN KLASSEN: I think that was
something that we tested a lot
up front, even before we got
into the interface design
stuff, because we didn't want
to set up situations--
or at least wanted to minimize
the situations--
where there would be
that lag time.
And we wanted to know how far
we could push that with it
still feeling like a
nice experience.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, cool.
Well, why don't we take another
one of the questions
from there?
Are there going to be more
practical uses for this modern
technique, do you think?
I would think so.
I mean, Google Creative Labs is
awesome at coming up with
new ways to push the technology
that's coming out
in Chrome and just on
the web in general.
And hopefully, if we all did
our jobs right, this will
inspire lots of people to come
up with new, practical ways to
use this technology.
The game's obviously really fun,
especially it was for us
to work on.
But I think there's a lot
that could be done
with this for sure.
JUSTIN GITLIN: Gaming
is a great example.
But yeah, I think there are
plenty of opportunities to
create new gestures and create
new interactions with the web.
And it's up to us to come
up with those, right?
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, and that's
one of the cool things about
Chrome Experiments is they are
designed to make it really
easy to show developers what is
possible and what's sort of
available on the web.
I'm kind of curious about one
of the comments in the case
study that you guys wrote.
And you talked about the
development tools becoming
more mature for the web.
And you talked about just some
of them that you use, like
CINEMA 4D and Blender.
What we're some of the other
tools that you liked, and what
was the part of the Chrome
Developer Tools that you found
most useful?
SEAN KLASSEN: I can speak
to some of the other
applications.
We still used Photoshop to do
the interface stuff, which I
know some people think is
old school, probably.
But it still is the best
method for us.
And then I think all the
developers these days are
using Sublime Text to
edit their code in.
And then when you get into like
the console and stuff in
Chrome, that's obviously
critical.
Justin probably can speak better
to that than I can.
JUSTIN GITLIN: Yeah, I think
the biggest tool in the
developer tools inside of Chrome
was the timeline with
watching memory usage, just to
make sure that our memory heap
didn't keep growing beyond
a reasonable boundary.
So that helped just kind
of track down memory
leaks along the way.
I think when you're running at
60 frames a second inside of a
video game environment, you
have to be really careful
about instantiating new objects
and rather reusing
objects whenever possible and
resetting values rather than
creating new objects
along the way.
So I think the memory
usage tool is really
helpful with that.
Obviously, the Network panel
will show you any requests
coming down, so that was helpful
in kind of reducing
the overall number
of requests.
So one thing that we did to sort
of minimize the amount of
requests was Base64 encoding
everything that we possibly
could that was a reasonable
size to Base64 encode.
So any image under around 10 K
in size, we'd Base64 encode
and put that directly into the
CSS or inline in the HTML as
an image source attribute.
As well you can use
Base64-encoded images as
three.js textures.
So three.js was the 3D library
that we used to create the 3D
environment.
As well, we Base64 encoded
the fonts.
So pretty much anything that
was going to be an external
request that was small enough,
we encoded to be inline with
the CSS or the JavaScript.
PETE LEPAGE: Now I remember
reading in the case study that
you said in particular with
Base64 encoding the fonts, did
you Base64 encode both the
different types of fonts?
And if so, do all browsers
download both of those?
Or do you do some smarts to say,
oh, this browser supports
this, so I'm going to send only
this type, this browser
supports this, so
that you reduce
the size of the download?
JUSTIN GITLIN: Yeah, all of
the modern browsers should
download them fine
at this point.
And we did have to do a
little rearranging.
I found one little bug in which
case a certain browser
needed the SVG font listed in
front of the WAF font to draw
into the canvas context
correctly.
But generally, we used an SVG
font and a WAF font, and that
seemed to be enough to cover
all the modern browsers.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
Well, why don't we take another
question from our
Moderator queue?
And again, the link if you
want to submit your own
questions is there
on the page.
But did you have any challenges
syncing the devices
in the screens?
And this is from
Fred in London.
SEAN KLASSEN: I think the
Google team had that
theoretically working when
they came to us.
And there was a little
bit of a challenge.
But that was not one of
the harder parts of
development at all.
JUSTIN GITLIN: And that system
was built not by us.
It was the development team that
also built the back end
for the Racer experiment
and the Jam with Chrome
experiment.
And they've sort of
gotten down to a
science at this point.
And that all works over
WebSockets once the connection
is established.
But there is a bit of up front
process that has to happen
between the two devices.
So there's the code that you get
when you start a game that
you use to connect the
two devices together.
And there's a bit of back-end
work that goes into generating
that code, the desktop telling
the back end, OK, we're using
this code, so give
me a server.
And once you get that server,
that's sort of stored on the
back end to create the
WebSocket connection.
And then on the mobile end, you
enter your code, and the
back end recognizes that code,
sends you back that server,
and that's how both devices
end up with the
same WebSocket server.
So that upfront process, there
was certainly a bit of
back-end work that
went into it.
But implementing it from the
front end was pretty easy with
the API that they had set up.
PETE LEPAGE: Oh nice, nice.
So it was just simply an API
library that you could call
into and just be like, hey, I
want to go do this, and it
just worked relatively
easily for you?
JUSTIN GITLIN: Because the back
end developers were great
at what they did, definitely.
And that's all built with the
Go language on Google's App
Engine and Compute Engine.
There's a whole series of
technologies that will create
like a private WebSocket server
for the two machines
per game and does a lot load
balancing up front.
And one interesting piece of
that equation was that on the
front end, we would receive a
list of up to three different
WebSocket servers, and we would
ping each one to try to
find the closest and fastest
WebSocket server to the user.
So there was some optimization
there to make for the quickest
experience on the front end.
PETE LEPAGE: Right.
So actually, that leads into
another interesting and I
think pretty important question
for mobile and just
for the web today in general.
And that's like, perf
matters, right?
Like, performance is
really important.
How did you guys think about
performance throughout the
entire building of
this experience?
SEAN KLASSEN: I'd say that was
really challenging because we
were using some things that we
hadn't necessarily developed
any kind of major projects
with before.
And luckily, we didn't have to
support every browser out
there for this because some of
the technologies don't work.
But it was something that we
had a balance with just
building the actual features
themselves.
So even close to launch, we've
noticed some bugs and stuff
that we've fixed, or just ways
to improve performance.
But there's always room to get
better at that, for sure.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, absolutely.
JUSTIN GITLIN: And I think some
of the things that I ran
into that were really big hits
on performance were in
three.js, the 3D library, the
more you have loaded into that
3D environment, the slower
it's going to go.
So in the 3D world, the lower
poly you can make your models,
the faster it's going
to perform.
So having fewer polygons
in your 3D meshes.
So that's something we went back
and forth a lot between
the code end and Sean's team,
who were building the 3-D
models for the skee ball lane
and any other 3D models that
were in the game.
So there was definitely a bit of
figuring out through their
tools, like CINEMA 4D and
Blender, on how to reduce the
polygon count before they
exported those models and sent
them over to me to drop into
the three.js scene.
Similarly, the physics library
that we were using, Physijs,
which is sort of a wrapper
around a 3D physics library
that is really easy to drop
into a three.js scene, the
more walls that you create that
are physics-enabled, the
more collision detection
has to happen.
So the less processing per
frame in the game that we
could execute, the better.
So we did some manual sort of
creation of the physics scene
that's invisible to
the user but is--
like the 3D models that they
see in the game are just a
facade over some 3D physics
objects that were created
manually in JavaScript.
PETE LEPAGE: Now did you guys do
any dynamic changing of the
amount of processing that's done
depending on how fast the
user's computer is or what
device they're running from or
anything like that?
JUSTIN GITLIN: We started to.
So I got into something along
those lines towards the end of
the project when some older
machines weren't
running quite as well.
But it turns out that some of
the aspects of three.js can't
really be changed on the fly.
And that's kind of what
I was checking.
Like if you were running at 20
frames a second versus 60
frames a second, I was
trying to drop
certain lighting or shadowing.
But it turns out that's pretty
hard to achieve without sort
of rebuilding the entire scene
without those features.
And that's due to three.js
being really good at
optimizing lighting and building
your shaders once and
storing those on
the video card.
And that's why three.js
runs so quickly.
But it also means that changing
certain things on the
fly is going to be
really tough.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah,
that makes sense.
SEAN KLASSEN: And WebGL was
pretty interesting to work
with, too, because we had to
try and detect a bunch of
different stuff.
Like some computers will allow
aliasing, some don't.
And there's a software component
to it to make it
work, but there's also
a hardware component.
And we can tell someone to
upgrade their software, but we
can't get them to upgrade
their hardware.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, that's
a little bit harder.
Yeah.
Why don't we take one of the
next questions in the
Moderator queue?
And Manuel, again, wants to
know, why didn't Chrome need
any special permissions to use
the gyroscope without having
to root the device or
anything like that?
JUSTIN GITLIN: I guess there
are certain things that are
clearly sort of violations
of somebody's privacy.
If a website's going to access
your camera without asking,
that shouldn't be allowed.
I think most people would
agree with that.
And we did work with the Google
Creative Lab team to
make sure that we were not
sending any sensitive user
data over the connections
because I
think Google clearly--
with that process that we had
to go through to sort of
outline every little bit of
information we're sending from
machine to machine--
that there's clearly a lot of
sensitivity to people's
privacy, which I definitely
appreciate.
And I think you can't really
glean anything from the
accelerometer about where
someone is or necessarily what
they're doing, or you
can't really be
creepy with that data.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
Yeah, no, that's very true.
One of the cool things is the
accelerometer, the device
motion, device orientation
stuff, is all part of the
standard HTML5 spec.
So that's available to any
developer who wants to build
for the web.
SEAN KLASSEN: Yeah, and I think
Androids and iPhones,
pretty much all smartphones
allow you access to that
within the browser
now, at least if
the software's current.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
Actually, that's a
good question.
Did you face any problems in
dealing with the experiment or
with anything like that, in
dealing with the device
orientation in device
motion stuff?
SEAN KLASSEN: Yeah, there was
definitely challenges.
PETE LEPAGE: And I'll
be right back.
SEAN KLASSEN: I think the
biggest thing was doing our
best to normalize the data to
one solution that worked
across everything that supported
those objects.
Some phones are better
than others.
But I think we came up with a
pretty good way to make it
work across everything
pretty much the same.
PETE LEPAGE: Awesome.
JUSTIN GITLIN: Yeah, just to
follow up on that, I think
certain phones will have a
faster rate at which the
accelerometer updates come in,
or the accelerometer event is
fired on a window.
So to pick those up at different
intervals, we
implemented some time stamping
along with each update to
normalize them across devices.
So maybe a device that's running
slower than another
device will hopefully feel
pretty much the same.
And we definitely went through a
lot of iterations of how the
swing, like as you swing your
phone to perform the roll
gesture, we went through a lot
of iterations where we would
think it felt good, but then
we'd hand it to somebody else
to beta test, and they just
wouldn't be able to do it.
So there was a lot of sort of
back and forth on watching how
people picked up a phone and
swung at and adjusting based
on what we saw.
It's easy as somebody who's
developing something like this
to get to a point where you
think, oh, this is great.
It works.
And then you hand it to someone
else, and they just
can't figure it out.
So there was definitely a lot
in terms of making the roll
gestures feel right.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
So another question, this one
actually comes from Paul
Kinlan, one of the guys on my
team who's based in London.
He wanted to know if there were
any features that don't
exist as part of the Open Web
Platform that you guys would
have liked to have had, that
would've been useful, that
would've made building this
experiment easier.
SEAN KLASSEN: I don't know.
I never even thought about that
because the job from the
start was to think what can we
do with this technology.
But I guess maybe like you're
somewhat limited in the speed
of your connections and how fast
things return from the
gyroscope and accelerometers
and stuff.
But I don't know.
I think it was pretty good.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
JUSTIN GITLIN: Yeah.
I guess one thing that I could
think of is given that the
game is based so much on the
WebSocket protocol, and that
does require obviously going
out to a remote server and
then coming back into your house
or office or wherever
you're playing, there are
certain corporate offices or
cell providers that block
WebSockets connections.
So that was a pretty big
challenge that we ran into,
and especially testing that
was really tough.
Somebody testing it may have
been in an office that was
blocking WebSockets, but we
didn't have access as
developers to get in there and
actually see what type of
errors were being thrown or how
that WebSocket connection
was closing automatically.
So we ran into some
pretty tough
issues along those lines.
So I think one thing that maybe
would have been cool
would be to not have to hit a
remote server to have your
WebSocket connection
established, or maybe some way
of syncing two devices and
creating that connection
without having to
hit a server.
That could be cool.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
In fact, that is coming.
That's coming as part of
the new WebRTC APIs.
And they're going to allow
peer to peer connections.
So today by going, you guys have
to go up to the server to
come back down.
With peer connections, you'll
have to go up to a server in
order to do the initial
handshake and figure out where
the other user is.
But once you've done that
initial handshake, you can
connect directly to the other
machine, which means much
faster connections, no longer
needing to deal with that,
hey, somebody else might
shut anything down.
Much better option, I think,
and a much better future.
SEAN KLASSEN: Yeah.
I think that the WebRTC stuff
is really exciting.
Because you can already see with
our experiment you can
make stuff feel pretty
real time.
And so you're going to be able
to send so much more
data back with that.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
And you guys have written a case
study that goes into some
more technical depth on
some of the stuff
on how you did this.
And you've got some great code
examples and that in there.
I've put the URL on screen
for people to check out.
But you can see that
case study there.
It's on HTML5 Rocks.
I think we're down towards
the end of the questions.
Is there anything that you guys
want to add or sort of
mention before we wrap up?
SEAN KLASSEN: I don't know.
I can't really think
of too much.
I'm thankful for the
opportunity to
be a part of this.
PETE LEPAGE: Well, it
was a great project.
I think you guys did a really
great job and should be very,
very happy with what you got.
JUSTIN GITLIN: I guess one sort
of thing that I've been
pondering a bit as we've wrapped
it up, I think there
is something about the
familiarity of skee ball that
I think made this really
successful in the hands of
people that may not be so
tech-savvy and may not be
quite as hip to what's hot
and new on the internet.
And that's something we've been
talking about, just why
do people sort of latch onto
it across the internet.
And I think it's due to some
amount of familiarity wrapped
into these sort of cutting-edge
technologies.
So I think that's a lesson to
take away just for other sort
of experimentation.
If you can make something that
may be using these new
technologies that feels so
cutting edge to us web
developers but make it feel not
so intimidating for the
average user to pick up and
start interacting with, I
think there's something
to be said for that.
SEAN KLASSEN: Yeah, I think
that's a good point.
You just have to learn
one new thing.
You don't have to learn two or
three or whatever new things.
So that's a lot less
intimidating.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
Well, I have one last question
for you guys.
What's your high score?
SEAN KLASSEN: Oh man.
I got a fireball on the first
turn of the game once.
So I got like 940
or something.
PETE LEPAGE: All right, 940.
And Justin?
JUSTIN GITLIN: All right.
I guess I've play this game so
many times that I don't know
that I have a good
answer for you.
I will say, though, while we
were at the Google I/O
conference, we had a competition
for how many 100s
we could get in a game.
And Sean and I both tied
at two 100s per game.
PETE LEPAGE: All right.
So just two.
So folks who are watching
at home, g.co/rollit.
You've got to beat two
100s in a row.
SEAN KLASSEN: Oh, just
in the game.
PETE LEPAGE: Just in the
game, all right.
Cool.
Well, guys, Sean, Justin,
thank you very much for
joining us today.
The URL for the documentation is
there that you can go check
out and have a look
at the case study
that these guys wrote.
And thanks for joining us.
We're going to be back next
week with a special Chrome
mobile event, where we're going
to be talking about
Chrome Racer and have
the developers
behind that join us.
So with that, I want to say
thanks, everybody, and thanks
for joining us.
All right, bye guys.
SEAN KLASSEN: Thank you.
Bye bye.